Jake: 你不吃
Jake: Aren't you eating?
Jake: 呵呵吃吧
Jake: Haha, go ahead and eat.
Jake: 你也不吃
Jake: You too?
Jake: 就咱俩吃
Jake: Just us two then.
Lucia: 有可能但我其实肯定也吃不了多少
Lucia: Maybe, but I probably can't eat much either.
Lucia: 但如果完全不吃我可能晚上睡觉
Lucia: But if I don't eat anything, I might have trouble sleeping.
Jake:那咱吃夜宵吧
Jake: Let's have a midnight snack then.
Jake: 要不哈哈哈
Jake: How about that? Haha.
Lucia:一会要吃饭
Lucia: We will eat soon.
Lucia: 就是你选择吃什么吧
Lucia: It's up to you what to eat.
Lucia:哈哈我都行
Lucia: Haha, I'm okay with anything.
Jake:我想喝粥
Jake: I want some porridge.
Katrina: 吃馄饨 那我自己点馄饨你报销行吗
Katrina: Eating wontons. If I order wontons, will you reimburse me?
Jake:咱都吃馄饨呗
Jake: Let's all have wontons.
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Lucia:呵呵呵
Lucia: Hehehe.
Alice:别吧的假呀
Alice: No way, that's fake.
Lucia:我算完了老板
Lucia: I'm done, boss.
Lucia:哈哈好
Lucia: Haha, okay.
Alice:请
Alice: Please.
Lucia:要给你发详单吗
Lucia: Do you want me to send you the detailed list?
Lucia:654.78
Lucia: 654.78.
Katrina: 你怎么花这么少钱
Katrina: How did you spend so little?
Lucia:啊 我的
Lucia: Ah, mine.
Lucia:可能是因为我我没有怎么点过外卖
Lucia: Maybe it's because I don't order takeout much.
Lucia:我每次都是大家点的时候
Lucia: I usually just add on when others order.
Lucia:我就跟着点一个嗯
Lucia: I just order along with everyone else, yeah.
Lucia:我甚至觉得我这个挺多
Lucia: I even think this is quite a lot.
Lucia:因为我加了我的疫苗
Lucia: Because I added my vaccine.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:谢谢老板 实际上我还要在打两针呢
Lucia: Thanks, boss. Actually, I still need two more shots.
Jake:好好好行 没问题
Jake: Alright, alright, no problem.
Katrina: 走上去一看就是一堆capo
Katrina: When you go up, you see a bunch of capos.
Katrina: 可是一看就是插头
Katrina: But it turns out they're plugs.
Lucia:我在接下来这一个月里还要打两针
Lucia: I need to get two more shots in the next month.
Katrina: 为什么要交换穿
Katrina: Why swap clothes?
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Shure的女友:你问他嘛想要强盗
Shure: Ask him, maybe he wants to be a robber.
Katrina: 可能他想要体验一下女生的这种感觉
Katrina: Maybe he wants to experience what it's like to be a girl.
Katrina: 但你穿的竟然还好
Katrina: But what you're wearing is fine.
Katrina: 不是很唯和 啊
Katrina: Not very girly. Ah.
Shure的女友:因为这是男款谢谢
Shure: Because it's men's style, thanks.
Katrina: 噢
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina: 够了哈哈哈
Katrina: Enough, hahaha.
Katrina: 快走吧
Katrina: Let's go quickly.
Katrina: 修硕哈哈
Katrina: Shure, haha.
Katrina: 被你折磨的
Katrina: You're torturing me.
Katrina: 拜拜
Katrina: Bye-bye.
Shure: 拜拜
Shure: Bye-bye.
Katrina: 别哭别哭
Katrina: Don't cry, don't cry.
Katrina: 哈哈哈别哭
Katrina: Hahaha, don't cry.
Katrina: 哈哈哈还下雨吗
Katrina: Hahaha, is it still raining?
Shure: 不下啦
Shure: No, it's stopped.
Katrina: ok
Katrina: Ok.
Alice:刚刚下雨了吗
Alice: Was it raining just now?
Lucia:刚下了哇
Lucia: Yeah, it just rained.
Katrina: 哎呦脚都麻了
Katrina: Oh my, my legs are numb.
Katrina: 我去我这么多
Katrina: Oh man, I have so much.
Alice:所以刚刚在谈啥呀
Alice: So, what were you discussing just now?
Lucia:刚刚在谈报销的事
Lucia: We were talking about reimbursements.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Alice:没参加也无所谓吧
Alice: It's no big deal if I didn't attend, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahahaha.
Tasha:你可以报
Tasha: You can report it.
Lucia:放心吧
Lucia: Don't worry.
Katrina: 把我笑死了
Katrina: That cracked me up.
Alice:啊怎么啦
Alice: Ah, what's up?
Katrina: 拜拜别回来了
Katrina: Bye bye, you're back.
Jake:拜拜 哈哈
Jake: Bye bye, haha.
Tasha:哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina: 生怕他们再回来烧钱
Katrina: Afraid they might come back and spend more.
Katrina: 我去算我的钱
Katrina: I'll go count my money.
Alice:你可以帮我按一下计算器吗我不想
Alice: Can you help me press the calculator? I don't want to.
Lucia:可以可以
Lucia: Sure, sure.
Alice:我来吧
Alice: I'll do it.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Jake:记账台是吧
Jake: This is the accounting table, right?
Jake:这就是账台
Jake: This is the accounting table.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Jake:记账台
Jake: Accounting table.
Lucia:我们也要做balance shit吗难道
Lucia: Do we also have to do the balance sheet?
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia:梯子帐
Lucia: Ladder accounts.
Alice:好啦我把账直接发给你吧
Alice: Alright, I'll just send the accounts to you.
Jake: 好 呃 你这个很专业
Jake: Okay, uh, you're very professional.
Alice:这是备忘录
Alice: This is a memo.
Alice:就是你可以放图片和文字
Alice: You can put pictures and text in it.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:嗯学习学习
Lucia: Yeah, let's learn.
Alice:这个
Alice: This.
Katrina: 哎呀哎我们直接算了
Katrina: Oh, let's just calculate directly.
Katrina: 你需要我们订单纸那个吗
Katrina: Do you need our order form?
Alice:备忘录里写也行
Alice: Writing it in the memo works too.
Katrina: 他不需要的话我们就直接算了
Katrina: If he doesn't need it, we'll just forget it.
Katrina: 我先点个粥喝
Katrina: I'll order some congee first.
Katrina: 看我的红包
Katrina: Check out my red envelope.
Lucia:我也可以用
Lucia: I can use it too.
Katrina: 一个一新币的红包
Katrina: A red envelope with one Singapore dollar.
Jake:嗯啊很多哈哈
Jake: Hmm, a lot, haha.
Alice:咦
Alice: Eh?
Alice:奇怪呢
Alice: Strange.
Alice:我给你发一个
Alice: I'll send you one.
Alice:为什么是这样的呢
Alice: Why is it like this?
Alice:给你发一个完整版的
Alice: I'll send you a complete version.
Katrina: 哎 想吃这个如意混沌
Katrina: Oh, I want to eat this "Ruyi Wonton".
Katrina: 你们吃啥
Katrina: What are you guys eating?
Jake:呃就你那个店里边
Jake: Um, just in your shop.
Jake:我们再找一找
Jake: We'll look around some more.
Katrina: 我吃如意馄饨
Katrina: I'll have Ruyi Wonton.
Katrina: 你们也吃馄饨吗
Katrina: Are you guys having wonton too?
Katrina: 你们想吃别的可以点
Katrina: If you want something else, you can order.
Jake:就是吃馄饨
Jake: Just wonton.
Jake:大家也没什么想
Jake: No one has any other preferences.
Jake:你们想吃什么也行
Jake: But if you want something else, it's fine too.
Jake:馄饨就是它
Jake: Wonton it is.
Alice:算了直接截图吧
Alice: Forget it, just take a screenshot.
Lucia:这是啥味的
Lucia: What flavor is this?
Katrina: 虾仁的啊
Katrina: Shrimp.
Lucia:超派虾仁的
Lucia: Super shrimp flavor.
Katrina: 哎大馄饨应该改成小馄饨
Katrina: Oh, the big wonton should be changed to small wonton.
Lucia:我也要这个吧
Lucia: I'll have this too then.
Lucia:我要香菜
Lucia: I want cilantro.
Lucia:我好了谢谢
Lucia: I'm good, thanks.
Katrina: 你吃吗嗯
Katrina: Are you eating? Hmm?
Katrina: 你不想吃
Katrina: You don't want to eat?
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Katrina: 你呢
Katrina: How about you?
Jake:一碗大馄饨50一颗
Jake: A bowl of big wontons, 50 each.
Tasha:sorry
Tasha: Sorry.
Lucia:没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay.
Katrina: 哎没电了
Katrina: Oh, out of battery.
Katrina: 还有多的充电宝呢
Katrina: Do we have extra power banks?
Jake:有上楼
Jake: Yeah, upstairs.
Jake:随便拔
Jake: Just take whichever.
Katrina: ok
Katrina: Okay.
Alice:我也弄成PDF
Alice: I'll make it a PDF too.
Jake:好好你来
Jake: Alright, go ahead.
Tasha:何止白干
Tasha: Not just for nothing.
Lucia:何止白干
Lucia: Not just for nothing.
Katrina: 楼上也没有多的充电宝啊
Katrina: There's no extra power banks upstairs either.
Lucia:你们知道那个梗吗
Lucia: Do you guys know that joke?
Lucia:    就是
Lucia: Pinduoduo is like...
Lucia:哇我这能说吗
Lucia: Wow, can I say this?
Katrina: 楼上也没有多的充电宝
Katrina: There's no extra power banks upstairs.
Lucia:是影响他们的品牌形象啊
Lucia:就是前几天
Lucia: Just a few days ago...
Jake:怕没有充电宝啊
Jake: Afraid there's no power banks, huh?
Katrina: 都是插了这种的
Katrina: They're all plugged in like this.
Katrina: 充电宝插了摄像机的
Katrina: The power banks are plugged into the cameras.
Jake:对对对是的
Jake: Yeah, yeah, that's right.
Katrina: 你可以
Katrina: You can...
Jake:楼上的那个摄像机好像关了是吧
Jake: The camera upstairs seems to be off, right?
Jake: 对楼上的不录了
Jake: Yeah, it's not recording upstairs.
Katrina: 哦哦
Katrina: Oh, okay.
Lucia:就是前前
Lucia: So, like...
Alice:所以怎么弄成PDF呢
Alice: So how do you make it a PDF?
Alice:哦这样啊
Alice: Oh, I see.
Alice:对然后呢
Alice: Right, and then?
Jake:然后选择打印机
Jake: Then select the printer.
Katrina: 点完了吗
Katrina: Did you click it?
Jake:就可以发送了
Jake: You can send it now.
Jake:这边是pdf
Jake: This is the PDF.
Katrina: 我手机呢
Katrina: Where's my phone?
Lucia:啊哦就是就是
Lucia: Uh, oh, it's like...
Lucia:前几天网上一个新闻就是
Lucia: A few days ago, there was this news online about Pinduoduo.
Lucia:就是大家知道竟业协议这回事
Lucia: You guys know about non-compete agreements, right?
Lucia:嗯对靖康可能知道
Lucia: Yeah, Jingkang probably knows.
Lucia:就是啊
Lucia: So, um...
Lucia:薇薇之前不知道的话就是没事
Lucia: Tasha, if you didn't know before, it's okay.
Lucia:这个反正是你到到工作的时候
Lucia: Anyway, you'll only encounter it when you start working.
Lucia:之后才会才会用到
Lucia: After that, you'll use it.
Lucia:所以然后就是有的大公司
Lucia: So, some big companies
Lucia:比如说就为了防止你入入职
Lucia: For example, to prevent you from joining
Lucia:跟他有竞争关系的其他公司
Lucia: A competing company
Lucia:他在入职时候会跟你签竞业协议就要
Lucia: They will have you sign a non-compete agreement when you join
Lucia:就是防止就是这些高层员工泄露商业
Lucia: To prevent these high-level employees from leaking business
Lucia:商业机密
Lucia: Trade secrets
Lucia:他本身是这样的一个
Lucia: That's the original purpose
Lucia:就是design purpose是这个
Lucia: The design purpose is this
Lucia:然后但是就是
Lucia: But now,
Lucia:有的公司现在就开始滥用这个
Lucia: Some companies are abusing it
Lucia:就是即使是基层员工入职
Lucia: Even for entry-level employees
Lucia:比如说刚刚刚毕业应届生这种
Lucia: For example, fresh graduates
Lucia:也让他们去签竞业协议
Lucia: They also have to sign non-compete agreements
Lucia:然后因为其实现在就是大家换工
Lucia: Because nowadays, changing jobs is very common
Lucia:换工作是很常见的嘛
Lucia: So, there have been cases before
Lucia:然后就有之前就有好好好些
Lucia: Where ordinary employees
Lucia:就是其实很普通的员工
Lucia: After leaving a company
Lucia:然后他们可能从这公司离职之后
Lucia: They join a new company where
Lucia:然后他进入了一个实际上吧
Lucia: Their job isn't even related to the previous one
Lucia:他负责的业务
Lucia: Their responsibilities
Lucia:可能跟之前公司也不是那么相关的
Lucia: Aren't even related to their previous company's work
Lucia:这么的新公司
Lucia: In the new company
Lucia:然后就是而且他们就是基层打工人
Lucia: And since they are entry-level workers
Lucia:所以手上也没有什么商业机密
Lucia: They don't have any trade secrets
Lucia:但是他们的员工司
Lucia: But their former company
Lucia:就拿这个竞业协议去起诉他们
Lucia: Uses the non-compete agreement to sue them
Lucia:然后让他们赔钱
Lucia: And makes them pay compensation
Lucia:就相当于是白干
Lucia: So it's basically working for free
Jake: 白干啊
Jake: Working for free?
Lucia:对相当于不光白干
Lucia: Yes, not only for free
Lucia:还要给员工公司赔钱
Lucia: They also have to pay the company
Lucia:就这个事情
Lucia: This whole thing
Lucia:前段时间
Lucia: Recently
Lucia:反正网上说了好几个这样的例子
Lucia: There have been several cases like this online
Lucia:都是我刚才说的那个
Lucia: Just like I mentioned earlier
Lucia:我就不说一遍了
Lucia: I won't repeat it
Lucia:这样一会你方便剪
Lucia: So it's easier for you to edit
Lucia:哈哈哈好好
Lucia: Hahaha, okay
Lucia:我场记一下
Lucia: I'll make a note
Lucia:我还是挺害怕他们来找我的
Lucia: I'm still a bit scared they'll come after me
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice:我没有
Alice: I didn't.
Jake:没有没有我把
Jake: No, no, I...
Jake:我们把    给逼掉就行
Jake: We can just remove Pinduoduo.
Jake:我们把逼给逼掉就行
Jake: We can just remove it.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice:杨老板我来算算你八字吧
Alice: Jake, let me calculate your Bazi.
Jake:怎么算
Jake: How do you do it?
Katrina: 感觉你有点小魔女的感觉
Katrina: Feels like you have a bit of a witch vibe.
Jake:请坐请坐
Jake: Please sit, please sit.
Alice:哦不用不用不用不用不用不用不用哎呀
Alice: Oh, no need, no need, no need, oh my.
Jake:请坐大师
Jake: Please sit, master.
Jake:大师请坐
Jake: Master, please sit.
Jake:哈哈大师不得坐着的
Jake: Haha, the master must sit.
Jake:站着大师
Jake: Stand, master.
Jake:没见过站着大师
Jake: Never seen a standing master.
Alice:但你得
Alice: But you have to...
Lucia:但是
Lucia: But...
Alice:你知道你的出生时间吗
Alice: Do you know your birth time?
Jake:我好像不知道
Jake: I think I don't.
Alice:那拜
Alice: Then bye.
Jake:好再见
Jake: Okay, goodbye.
Alice:百搭 直接百搭
Alice: That works, totally works.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina: 可以算我的吗
Katrina: Can you do mine?
Katrina: 我知道我是农历还是阳历
Katrina: I know if it's lunar or solar.
Katrina: 呃你得出精确到时间
Katrina: Uh, you need to be precise about the time.
Katrina: 我下午1点出生的
Katrina: I was born at 1 PM.
Katrina: 下午1点可以
Katrina: 1 PM is fine.
Alice:1点前一点后
Alice: Before or after 1 PM?
Katrina: 一点零几分了
Katrina: A bit after 1 PM.
Lucia:不过法律意义上说我这应该不算造谣
Lucia: But legally speaking, this isn't considered slander.
Lucia:因为
Lucia: Because...
Lucia:我只是复述了我在网上看到的信息
Lucia: I'm just repeating what I saw online.
Alice:那你的生日是
Alice: So, your birthday is?
Katrina: 嗯阳历还是农历
Katrina: Uh, solar or lunar?
Katrina: 阳历2001
Katrina: Solar, 2001.
Lucia:反正我好多同学都是学法的
Lucia: Anyway, a lot of my classmates study law.
Lucia:都够组一个律师团了
Lucia: Enough to form a legal team.
Alice:91年12月
Alice: December 1991.
Katrina: 21
Lucia:下午1点
Lucia: 1 PM
Alice:1点啊 1点无所谓
Alice: 1 PM? 1 PM is fine.
Alice:1点几分都一样
Alice: Any minute after 1 PM is fine.
Alice:这个不用
Alice: No, we don't.
Tasha:哦对你们点饭了 哎
Tasha: Oh right, you guys ordered food. Hey.
Katrina: 那你可以睡觉
Katrina: Then you can sleep.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 今天睡了一下午好爽啊
Katrina: I slept the whole afternoon, felt great!
Jake:是确实
Jake: Yeah, definitely.
Katrina: 而且醒来都都下雨了
Katrina: And when I woke up, it was raining.
Jake:下雨天适合睡觉
Jake: Rainy days are perfect for sleeping.
Alice:请求超时
Alice: Request timed out.
Alice:我们是现场报销吗
Alice: Do we get reimbursed on the spot?
Jake:可以
Jake: Yes.
Katrina: 哎呦 哎我买一支彩色笔好像没看见
Katrina: Oh, I bought a colored pen but couldn't find it.
Katrina: 一支彩色笔 没送吗
Katrina: A colored pen, wasn't it delivered?
Lucia:没送吗
Lucia: Wasn't it delivered?
Katrina: 哎取了取了
Katrina: Oh, I got it, got it.
Katrina: 我听谁说好像看见了
Katrina: I heard someone say they saw it.
Lucia:好像看了但是
Lucia: I think I saw it but...
Lucia:后来又放哪去就不知道了
Lucia: Then I don't know where it went.
Jake:这边还有一袋
Jake: There's another bag here.
Jake:不知道是什么
Jake: Not sure what's inside.
Jake:不知道谁垫的
Jake: Not sure who put it here.
Katrina: 我的我的
Katrina: It's mine, it's mine.
Katrina: 我今天早上找我的牙膏没找到
Katrina: I couldn't find my toothpaste this morning.
Lucia:哦我还买了碘伏和生理盐水
Lucia: Oh, I also bought iodine and saline solution.
Lucia:不过那东西会也只有我用了
Lucia: But I'm the only one who uses it.
Lucia:没事就算我那个啥也行
Lucia: It's fine, I can use it myself.
Lucia:反正他也就一新币
Lucia: Anyway, it costs just one dollar.
Tasha:一新币
Tasha: One dollar.
Lucia:对一新币
Lucia: Yes, one dollar.
Lucia:算了不管他了
Lucia: Forget it, doesn't matter.
Lucia:不算了
Lucia: Never mind.
Jake:对回新加坡少坐一次公交车
Jake: Yeah, that's like skipping one bus ride in Singapore.
Jake:少坐半次公交车
Jake: Or half a bus ride.
Katrina: 然后我还买了花呢
Katrina: And I also bought flowers.
Lucia:我美团上的单子比较少刚就忘
Lucia: I had fewer orders on Meituan, just forgot.
Lucia:算了不也没关系
Lucia: Never mind, it's okay.
Lucia:哈哈哈不用
Lucia: Hahaha, no need.
Lucia:争取用这个哈哈哈
Lucia: I'll try to use this, hahaha.
Lucia:觉得我现在又饱又饿好奇怪啊
Lucia: I feel both full and hungry, so weird.
Jake:就是几个胃
Jake: You just have multiple stomachs.
Lucia:其实我有点想吃东西
Lucia: Actually, I feel like eating something.
Lucia:但是就是我没有那种特别饿的感觉
Lucia: But I don't feel particularly hungry.
Lucia:刚才吃了一大块
Lucia: I just ate a big piece.
Tasha:好腻刚刚吃了一块
Tasha: It's so greasy, I just had a piece.
Jake:最多吃一个
Jake: You can only eat one at most.
Jake:那确实一天最多吃一个
Jake: Yeah, you can only eat one a day at most.
Lucia:很好吃但是吃多了确实会有一点
Lucia: It's delicious, but if you eat too much, it's a bit...
Lucia:太甜了
Lucia: Too sweet.
Lucia:糖分摄入超标
Lucia: Sugar intake overload.
Tasha:然后今天晚上就把房子拆了就行是吧
Tasha: Then tonight we just demolish the house, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha:那我现在去拆
Tasha: I'll go demolish it now.
Tasha:然后晚上就不用拆了
Tasha: Then we won't have to demolish it tonight.
Jake:对 好
Jake: Yes, good.
Jake:现在拆吧
Jake: Go demolish it now.
Jake:合影合影
Jake: Let's take a group photo.
Lucia:冲冲冲
Lucia: Go, go, go!
Tasha:你也拆
Tasha: You demolish too.
Jake:可以报
Jake: You can report it.
Lucia:我也拆
Lucia: I'll demolish too.
Jake:怎么报
Jake: How to report?
Jake:就你你给我那PDF你写一个
Jake: Just give me that PDF you wrote.
Jake:总帐呗
Jake: The final account.
Katrina: 我这个太杂了
Katrina: Mine is too messy.
Katrina: 我天
Katrina: Oh my.
Alice:就在568.19 刚摁的这些线
Alice: It's at 568.19, just pressed these wires.
Jake:就就这些是吧 对
Jake: Just these, right? Yes.
Jake:恭喜结账成功
Jake: Congratulations on the successful payment.
Katrina: 20 20
Katrina: 20, 20.
Alice:OK了
Alice: OK.
Alice:哇听见田螺姑娘了
Alice: Wow, I heard the snail girl.
Alice:你是在帮我
Alice: Are you helping me?
Alice:哇塞
Alice: Wow.
Alice:这绿色好好看啊
Alice: This green looks so good.
Jake:  还没算完
Jake: Haven't finished calculating yet.
Katrina: 哼哼
Katrina: Hmm-hmm.
Jake:我靠 害怕了
Jake: Whoa, that scared me.
Katrina: 哈哈有很多小东西
Katrina: Haha, there are a lot of little things.
Katrina: 然后各个平台
Katrina: And on different platforms.
Katrina: 我点过饭
Katrina: I've ordered food.
Katrina: 也帮忙付过超市的钱
Katrina: And helped pay for groceries.
Jake:害怕你妈给我这么长一个账单吗
Jake: Are you afraid your mom will give me such a long bill?
Katrina: 不止在计算机里呢
Katrina: It's not just in the computer.
Katrina: 算完了 1,692.2
Katrina: Done calculating. 1,692.2.
Jake:拿球球是啥玩意
Jake: What's this thing called "ball"?
Katrina: 嗯没记
Katrina: Hmm, didn't note it down.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Whoa.
Katrina: 这样的今天晚上做个pdf
Katrina: For this, I'll make a PDF tonight.
Katrina: 一个超市400多
Katrina: One supermarket, over 400.
Jake:大件大件都是啥
Jake: What are the big expenses?
Jake:大的大花销都是啥
Jake: What are the big costs?
Katrina: 两两顿饭
Katrina: Two meals.
Katrina: 然后房子预算那500
Katrina: And 500 for the house budget.
Katrina: 嗯拉满了
Katrina: Hmm, maxed out.
Katrina: 然后买那个花什么的那边300多
Katrina: Then buying flowers, over 300.
Katrina: 300多然后那个超市450好像
Katrina: Over 300, and the supermarket, around 450.
Katrina: 然后饭点了一顿170
Katrina: Then one meal was 170.
Katrina: 然后点了一顿120
Katrina: Then another meal was 120.
Jake:你刚都录下来了
Jake: Did you record all that?
Jake:反正就是是吧
Jake: Anyway, right?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake:那行
Jake: Alright then.
Jake:回头就这个单独的任务给你做一个
Jake: Later, I'll give you this separate task.
Jake:一千六百九十二点
Jake: One thousand six hundred and ninety-two point...
Katrina: 一六九二点二
Katrina: One six nine two point two.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Jake:你这连续三个2
Jake: You got three twos in a row.
Jake:刚刚也有一个连续三个6
Jake: There were also three sixes in a row just now.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Katrina: :啊那就0.17
Katrina: Ah, then it's 0.17.
Jake:喂
Jake: Hello?
Jake:在结个工资
Jake: Settling wages.
Jake:还有个抢过什么红包
Jake: Plus some grabbed red envelopes.
Katrina: 我好像抢了两三个
Katrina: I think I grabbed two or three.
Katrina: 一个161一个14
Katrina: One was 161, another was 14.
Katrina: 一个159
Katrina: 159.
Katrina: 我靠
Katrina: Damn.
Katrina: 150  300
Katrina: 150, 300.
Katrina: 你直接拿2100减这个吧
Katrina: Just subtract this from 2,100.
Katrina: 嗯嗯我看看啊 450加上
Katrina: Hmm, let me see, 450 plus...
Jake:嗯嗯嗯
Jake: Hmm, hmm, hmm.
Alice:卧槽
Alice: Whoa.
Alice:真的吗
Alice: Really?
Katrina: 74加上
Katrina: 74 plus...
Jake:其实是你们最后四天
Jake: Actually, it's your last four days.
Jake:怎么了
Jake: What's up?
Katrina: 985
Katrina: 985.
Katrina: 我抢了985啊
Katrina: I grabbed 985.
Jake:真的985 呵呵呵
Jake: Really 985? Haha.
Jake:牛逼
Jake: Awesome.
Katrina: 那就2,100减985
Katrina: So, 2,100 minus 985.
Katrina: 哎不是2,000
Katrina: Wait, not 2,000.
Katrina: 是两
Katrina: It's 2...
Jake:我我来算一下
Jake: Let me calculate.
Jake:就是其实是最后四天
Jake: So actually, it's the last four days.
Jake:最后四天没有没结账
Jake: The last four days' bill wasn't settled.
Jake:四天是1,200
Jake: Four days is 1,200.
Jake:然后你抢了个 啥也没抢
Jake: And you grabbed... nothing.
Jake:那你就是1,200
Jake: So, you have 1,200.
Jake:就是从
Jake: It's from...
Jake:周五周五周六周日周一这四天
Jake: Friday, Saturday, Sunday, Monday, these four days.
Jake:一共1,200
Jake: Total 1,200.
Jake:然后这四天你一个红包都没抢着
Jake: And during these four days, you didn't grab any red envelopes.
Katrina: 我前面抢了一个74一个300的
Katrina: I grabbed one 74 and one 300 earlier.
Jake:对就是前面
Jake: Yes, that was earlier.
Jake:周五之前的就清掉了
Jake: Before Friday, it was cleared.
Jake:你还抢了74
Jake: You also grabbed 74.
Katrina: 74是第一天
Katrina: 74 was the first day.
Katrina: 你说你发错了
Katrina: You said you sent it wrong.
Katrina: 那个 哦
Katrina: That... oh.
Jake:发错了 OK 发错了
Jake: Sent it wrong, okay, sent it wrong.
Jake:74 你发错了
Jake: 74, you sent it wrong.
Jake:那就给你扣74
Jake: So, we'll deduct 74.
Katrina: :嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:哎你74也还给我了
Jake: Hey, you returned the 74 to me.
Katrina: 但你没收啊
Katrina: But you didn't take it.
Jake:啊行行行
Jake: Oh, alright, alright.
Katrina: 我要搜一下昨天
Katrina: I need to search for yesterday's stuff.
Jake:嗯嗯
Jake: Mm, mm.
Katrina: 富了
Katrina: I'm rich now.
Jake:有钱了
Jake: Got money now.
Jake:可以坐飞机回家了
Jake: You can fly home now.
Katrina: 哈哈哈真的
Katrina: Haha, really.
Jake:可以可以到机场这边取机票
Jake: You can get your ticket at the airport here.
Alice:这还有什么需要收拾的吗
Alice: Is there anything else we need to pack?
Alice:这个
Alice: This one?
Katrina: 我可以带点东西回去
Katrina: I can take some stuff back.
Tasha:收拾完了 啊
Tasha: All packed up, ah.
Tasha:我可以摘眼镜了吗
Tasha: Can I take off my glasses now?
Katrina: 也可以拿点东西回去
Katrina: You can take some stuff back too.
Alice:拿什么拿什么
Alice: Take what, take what?
Katrina: 想拿什么拿什么
Katrina: Take whatever you want.
Alice:就是这些
Alice: Just these?
Katrina: 拿点咖啡啊啥的
Katrina: Take some coffee or something.
Alice:他那个啥拿走没呀
Alice: Did he take that thing?
Alice:他需要那个什么手冲的那些东西
Alice: He needs those hand-brewed things.
Katrina: 那是他自己的那个魔法豆豆的那个
Katrina: That's his own magic beans thing.
Alice:哦哦我的意思是他需要的原料啥
Alice: Oh, oh, I mean the materials he needs.
Alice:他可以拿走点
Alice: He can take some.
Alice:因为我里面有那个机器
Alice: Because I have the machine inside.
Alice:薇薇你需要给你收拾点啥东西吗
Alice: Tasha, do you need me to pack anything for you?
Alice:我现在收拾啥
Alice: What should I pack now?
Tasha:不用我房间也收拾好了
Tasha: No need, my room is packed too.
Alice:你这些原料什么的你看你就用得上了
Alice: You see, these materials, you can use them.
Jake:嘿嘿嘿
Jake: Hehe.
Jake:外边有只猫
Jake: There's a cat outside.
Jake:喂猫的
Jake: Feeding the cat.
Alice:真的吗嗯
Alice: Really, huh?
Katrina: 它走了吗
Katrina: Did it leave?
Tasha:对 但是你不理它
Tasha: Yeah, but if you ignore it,
Tasha:它一会就回来了
Tasha: It'll come back in a bit.
Tasha:它只会离人半丈远
Tasha: It only stays half a zhang away from people.
Alice:关键这也拿走没啥用啊
Alice: But it's useless to take this.
Jake:想拿就拿
Jake: Take it if you want.
Jake:随便拿点
Jake: Just grab something.
Katrina: 哎呦喝吃点西瓜又不太舒服
Katrina: Oh no, eating some watermelon made me feel uncomfortable.
Alice:拿来也没有用啊
Alice: Bringing it won't be useful anyway.
Alice:用不上主要是家不在这
Alice: It's not useful mainly because home isn't here.
Alice:小姐姐
Alice: Miss.